what up guys welcome to today's episode
of pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery craziness and debauchery
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and let's get
started so today we are going to be
talking about Sofia Vergara and her
husband Joe
manganelio all right I did my best all
right stop sipping the coffee you know I
did my best all right so
for those of you that don't know Sophia
is an actress that has been famous for
being on Modern Family and the crazy
thing about her is she's actually been
married a couple times she has a son and
the crazy thing is she was one of the
first cases that I heard her ex-husband
is actually suing her to get her eggs
because she didn't want to have kids
with her ex-husband and the crazy thing
is they're actually getting divorced for
the same reason that she does not want
children and this is why you know a lot
of times in the red pill like before
guys find it they think they can change
a woman but the truth of the matter is
if a woman doesn't want to be a mother
she doesn't want kids or she already has
a kid
um it's really not gonna change her mind
and the funny thing is she was 44 when
they got married she's 51 now and I I
really question why on Earth
you would think she could have kids at
that point but I guess it led to the
demise of their relationship so a couple
things I wanted to talk about how she
talks about him so you know in 2023
there are some real reasons for divorce
right right guys I mean for richer or
for poorer in sickness and in Hell till
death do we part there are real reasons
that women have for divorce and when we
divorce our husbands it's just because
they're terrible abusers and the reasons
we give are very valid so according to
one Insider now guys this is alleged
like they haven't said any of this
publicly but you know this we we do
follow the celebrity gossip so we're
going to talk about this according to
one Insider despite initially bonding
over their differences Sophia and Joe's
contrasting personalities made their
marriage more difficult over time Joe is
a big kid he loves playing Dungeons and
Dragons he loves wrestling he is all
about video games superhero movies comic
books going to concerts huge NFL fan he
chases fun The Insider said adding that
the Magic Mike actor loves being out and
just having a good time they went on to
say that Joe's fun-loving side combined
with his ability to be serious it was
time to get to work was initially a huge
attraction for Sofia who says they
who they say is more concerned with the
Finer Things in life she has been told
her entire life she is super hot and
beautiful it has really gotten to her
head The Insider said of the Modern
Family star she has a temper and gets
upset over stupid things really easily
where Joe tries to let things Bond
bounce off of him and go with the flow
The Source said that their contrasting
attitudes towards life wasn't such an
issue at the start of their relationship
but that over time the true versions of
themselves started showing and they just
got annoyed with each other
wow this is you know
very much grounds for divorce with vows
you made with
God you know and I know what I was
saying earlier the kids thing is a more
valid reason for divorce but my question
is would you would you expect with a 44
year old chick
like I don't know what what you thought
was at the other end of this with a
woman over 40. like what was the the
child prospects for you but whatever
whatever
they stopped wanting to be together and
stopped hanging out because something so
little would often trigger an attitude
that would bug them The Insider alleged
their attitudes and everything were
completely different and something like
that is extremely draining for a
relationship apparently the little
arguments became too tiresome and Joe
and Sophia decided that it was easier
and more relaxing not being together so
let me get this great we want a divorce
so it's easier and more relaxing and
let's just be honest guys men don't
really argue like that
let's just call it what it is when
there's a lot of arguments I think it's
the fault of the woman yes I know I know
it's the fault of the man for arguing
back right but it's like if you have a
boss do you argue with your boss
if the if the employee starts arguing
with the boss he gets fired right and it
would be quite weird to see the boss
arguing back with an employee just get
rid of them so I guess maybe that's what
we can see happened in this situation
people will say that they will be
friendly they will but the romance part
of things is over they grew apart for
from something that could have been
really good it goes without saying that
we can't be sure of what actually caused
the split until we hear it from The Duo
themselves
so it's best to take this with a grain
of salt however there have been a number
of signs over recent months to suggest
that the decision to part ways has been
in the works for some time
um alarm Bells started ringing way back
in August of last year when Joe did not
accompany Sophia to Sarah Halen's
wedding to well Adams instead Sophia
brought her 31 year old son who she
shares with her first husband Joe
Gonzalez
all right a giant red flag
if a woman keeps her ex-husband's last
name
that is not your girl
that's his girl literally like she has
his last name
I know a lot of times they'll say in the
red pill word you're met but we see
patterns we see patterns if a woman
doesn't want to take your last name
it's not a good sign but the point of
the matter is guys we have real reasons
for divorce women are just divorcing
their husbands left and right for real
reasons I mean let's think of all the
divorces in the media it's not just
because women feel like it
I mean we have real valid reasons for
divorce
uh when we feel like we're being abused
when we feel like we're being hurt when
we feel like we're being wrong when we
feel like the relationship is toxic
whatever we feel just is automatically
the truth we should just divorce divorce
divorce there's another divorce in the
media
that was really
um Justified because women have real
reasons for divorce okay we just divorce
for good reasons so
Ariana Grande has gotten divorced now
who is Ariana Grande she is a pop singer
that really has been America's
sweetheart of the decade
um now this is no hate towards her at
all but we kind of see the normal like
phases that women go through who did she
date in her 20s the bad boy Mac Miller
and I know I know he passed away
um so rest in peace but I I can't say he
he's like your typical nice stand-up guy
right like that he doesn't
come across as like the the guy you take
home to Mom so a couple years ago Ariana
Grande did get married to a real estate
developer Picture Perfect like he just
seems like a good stand-up guy
and the problem is when women have a
crazy ex and then try to settle within
settle down with a nice more stable guy
they miss the drama they they like it
they'll never be like satisfied a lot of
the time not always but a lot of the
time
um okay so Ariana Grande's now estranged
husband Dalton Gomez is devastated by
the Paris divorce but hopefully but
hopeful they'll reconcile despite the
singers wanting to move forward
Ariana Grande's now estranged husband
Dalton Gomez isn't handling their split
as well as the singer shocking the
woman's over at the man's not it's
almost like men take the vows Men
actually take vows you know what I mean
women we just like say things we're like
oh I feel one way or the other way
whatever okay go go down
um all right a separation is not what he
wanted he wanted the fairy tale happy
ending it's not looking that way though
it was recently reported that Ariana is
looking to move forward another source
claims that Dalton still hopes they'll
reconcile so this is the guy like you
know it just looks like a nice a nice
nice guy Dalton is really hoping to make
things work with Ariana despite the
rocky patches that they've been through
he isn't ready to give up on the
marriage he saw himself spending the
rest of his life with Ariana and will do
anything to get past this US Weekly also
reported that Ariana is ready to put her
failed marriage behind her and and
determined to move forward
so we have one guy that says I'm willing
to work this out
and the woman says I am not willing to
work this out now everyone says I'm the
bad guy when I say we should ban divorce
because this is crazy
it's crazy that women can just like feel
like leaving not really give a good
reason and leave when they both took
vows to stay together for Life an
Insider claimed that the former couple
had amicably decided on divorcing as
they felt it was the right move
considering their differences as sad as
it seems the consensus on both sides is
that is ultimately for the best how
a consensus if he said he's hoping to
reconcile
that's like when women are like it was
Mutual it was not mutual that usually
means it was us
it was it was a mutual decision that I
brought up pushed forward and left
um furthermore they also noted that the
singer-songwriters loved ones are happy
that she is taking steps in her personal
life to do what is best for her listen
to that listen listen
they they're happy she's taking steps in
her personal life to do what is best for
her
not everybody else for her and this is
the problem even the families enable
this because they tell us as women we
should do what's best for us now what's
best for the family what's best for us
you know I'm glad that they didn't have
any kids involved like at least if
there's no kids it's like all right but
it's a me me me me me me
culture where we tell women that they're
supposed to put themselves first if
anything it would make more sense for
men to put themselves first because they
have to to take care of their families
but women it makes absolutely no sense
for us to put ourselves first so since
the shocking news emerged Grande has
also scrubbed her Instagram clean of any
wedding photos as of now she still has
the pictures up with Gomez and claims
the pair are remaining friends despite
having called it quits back in January
sources revealed to U.S weekly that
claims the pair have been having issues
for quite some time ultimately decided
to split through the rough path Ariana
and Dalton have been going through some
issues for months now The Insider had
revealed after the song stress was
spotted without her ring I can't imagine
that there would be any problems with a
woman that released a song called God is
a woman
now I'm I mean and this is the thing
like
marriage is so much about mindset okay
and if you go into marriage with the
wrong mindset
then it just doesn't work it does not
work when we have this egalitarian model
God is a woman women and men are equal
it it just it genuinely doesn't work and
we could say that oh I don't know what
I'm talking about because I've never
been married that's what they'll say but
it's like water is wet I can see what's
in front of me whenever we have women
that have this mindset that they are
equal to men that they are on the same
level as their husband it never works in
the long run because no country has two
kings imagine if there was a co-king or
every we we both Kings have to decide if
they go to war no it's not it doesn't
work there is always a hierarchy in
every society and every civilization and
in our relationships and when you
believe that we're equal you tell men
that we're equal you tell women that
we're equal and that we have the same
reasoning and logic skills it does a
disservice to men and to women like a
lot of times people will say oh you just
hate women I think the message that we
send is a disservice to women because it
lies to us we can't even have an ideal
look obviously this entire generation no
one's been raised to be wives no one's
been raised to be husbands but it's like
how do we learn how to do that if we
can't even admit what the goal is right
we can't even admit okay we should
listen and obey our husband I genuinely
think that it is more important to
respect your husband than to love him
because a relationship
can work without love but it cannot work
without respect because we see the
results of women picking men on our
feelings I mean why does India have a 99
marriage rate a one percent divorce rate
now I I know it's getting more
westernized maybe it's going away from
that but the point is they have arranged
marriages there it is not based off of
your feelings it is based off of Duty
respect
um and family and Community it's not
based off of the way we feel and it's
like we can't even go towards fixing
this problem because the media and the
messaging is we are equal God is a woman
it's like this is the messaging we have
in our society where we can't even admit
like what the goal is in a marriage you
know I hope they work it out I really do
but I'm not shocked it didn't work out
you know if you if you listen to the
messaging in her songs it's really just
the wrong mindset and it's sad because
you really see the fate of singers like
this Selena Gomez of Taylor Swift now
Ariana Grande that write these love
songs where they're always the victim
that write these songs where we should
just empower the women and I I don't
even think it's conscious they really
seem like nice people but the issue is
that mindset is toxic and if we don't
have men that are calling out this
mindset if we don't have women that are
saying this is wrong this is out of
order then we're never going to see
improvements because we can't even admit
what the goal is next story Miranda
Lambert recently has caught some hot
water Miranda Lambert is the country
singer of the decade I grew up listening
to Miranda Lambert she is a fiery
country singer with a literally a
beautiful voice um I love her song The
House That Built Me like she has had so
many number one records if you listen to
country music at all you know who
Miranda Lambert is
um country music I think that country
music is one of the few genres we have
left but barely anyways Miranda Lambert
was giving a concert and scolded a woman
for taking a selfie at the concert
um let's let's watch
[Music]
right here for a sec Danny I'm sorry
[Applause]
these girls are worried about the selfie
and not listening to the song it's
pissing me off a little bit
[Applause]
[Music]
we're here
[Applause]
trying to start again
oh that wasn't even that bad
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
okay that was the first time I actually
watched the clip I thought it was going
to be so much worse
I mean I'll see okay
so there's a lot of people that said
Miranda was wrong for this I mean these
girls spent over a thousand dollars on
their tickets and you know in a way I
can
understand where they're coming from but
at the end of the day Miranda Lambert
has worked her whole career
to build a show
and we get these women coming in where
they're not even watching the concert
they're just taking selfies I recently
went to a concert and it's actually
crazy how little like women will watch
the concert and the whole time they'll
just be like selfie video selfie I
understand like one or two snapshots but
I'm just thinking if she had this
reaction
how long were they doing this like I
doubt it was one picture it was probably
the whole time selfie selfie video
selfies
okay she said I'm gonna stop here for a
second these girls are worried about the
selfie and not listening to the song now
is this that this that crazy of a
request
because I'm just thinking like if you're
front row
at a concert like you would think you
would be there to watch it it's like
women we just can't do anything we can't
we can't go anywhere without worrying
about social media first and a lot of
people were taking the girls side and
saying they paid for the tickets they
have a right to do whatever they want
but she also has a right to require
whatever she wants at a concert I went
to a Dave Chappelle show a couple months
ago and it's gotten so bad that they
take phones at concerts so people will
listen and I didn't really think she
came across rude I didn't think she
really said anything that unreasonable
and honestly the way people were
reacting and like the headlines I've
seen I totally thought she like yelled
at them but all she really did was ask
them to put their phones away
and kept singing I don't really think
that makes her a [__] I don't really
think that makes her crazy
and I think if the woman has worked for
a decade
to put on a show she she has a right to
require that from her fans now what are
the comments say
um by the way the correct answer here is
Miranda Lambert is a huge brat imagine
being such a diva that you scold fans
who paid a premium for front row seats
in demand how they must enjoy the music
such a brat I I just really didn't think
it was that bad well and the other thing
to consider is you know I'm an
Entertainer I play guitar I'll do I'll
do music it's really distracting as an
Entertainer when the people in the front
row are on the phone their phones the
whole time guys I I doubt this was one
selfie I doubt that she was just they
took a couple pictures and she got mad I
am sure it was like an hour straight of
selfies and I'm telling you this because
I watched it I watched it you know me
and the whole the whole team went to the
weekend like the other week they gave us
like free um I don't know
these like seats and like a special box
I don't even I don't know but
it was crazy like all of the girls were
just on their phones the entire time we
understand a picture or two here or
there but at some point it's just like
are you here to watch the concert and
not only that it's distracting to the
other people at the concert imagine
being next to a group that the whole
time is just talking taking selfies you
know I think the artists have a right to
demand that the people at their concert
don't act like children you know if
people get too drunk at a concert they
get escorted out I have never seen
people get mad at a man being escorted
out because he was too drunk I have
never seen anyone but whenever someone
holds a woman accountable for bad
behavior we get mad and that's the thing
it's like you can't tell women to do
anything without people saying oh the
women are victims the poor women
when the truth of the matter is when we
see a man that's too drunk and he gets
escorted out nobody questions it no one
says well why he paid for those tickets
doesn't even be a right to enjoy it how
you want no you do not have the right to
do whatever you want at a concert There
are rules and there are social norms and
if you break either of those the artists
have a right to tell you to leave so I'm
team Miranda on this one yeah
all right they it's so crazy they all
take the women's side
they paid to be there and want to post a
selfie on their very own social media or
a short clip to their Tick Tock
Instagram
um with her music in the background to
say yay Miranda concert so happy she has
the nerve to call and shame them WTF
they paid for her tickets and were not
disrespecting or disruptive she thinks
she's better than she is I think Karen
Lambert was wrong this is how
how people today commemorate milestones
in their lives with selfies just saying
they bought the tickets I would have
left I don't have time for
self-righteous entitled people no no no
no no no no no it's just like why do we
guys you know at some point being front
row at a concert and taking selfies with
the flash on not paying attention to the
artist at all is disrespectful and we
have a right to demand that women don't
act like children at the concerts and my
gut feeling is it wasn't one selfie it
wasn't two selfies it was an hour full
of selfies and she was sick of it
Miranda Lambert has a right to escort
drunk men out she also has a right to
escort women out that are so addicted to
their phones that they can't watch the
concert
if this happened to a man I guarantee
nobody would care but whenever it's a
woman it's all the poor woman oh even
though genuinely all she did was stop
the concert tell them to put their
phones away she didn't escort them out
she didn't tell him to leave she just
said it's disrespectful and my question
is let's let's not talk about how it
makes us feel was she right or was she
wrong is it disrespectful to be on your
phone an entire concert yes or no
but so often in society we focus on how
the question makes us feel rather than
the question and it doesn't make you a
bad person to like check someone's
Behavior even if they're fans paying for
a ticket we go through life never having
our Behavior checked and honestly as
women sometimes we need it sometimes we
need to be checked and it's not the end
of the world so
another uh podcast that talks about
checking women constantly is fresh and
fit now guys I will tell you when I
first started listening to fresh and fit
they would trigger me a lot because I
just thought they were so rude so
disrespectful to the women that came on
the show until I got into their shoes
life is funny I swear life is funny and
then I started doing
um what they did I did a live show like
them
and I realized God damn women will
disrespect you ten times you check them
once and they play victim you check them
once and and you're the bad guy you're
the big meanie and I realize that women
will whine and whine and whine and I'm
not even saying I've never done this in
my life I probably have but we live in a
society that men can never check women
for their behavior without being called
toxic manipulative controlling so it's
funny because they used to kind of
trigger me when I would watch them until
I I got red pilled and I realized
they're right about a lot of things so
at what point though does trust factor
into that like let's say for friends
getting married or I don't know her
friends celebrating a birthday there's
15 of her friends going out she wants to
join yeah at what point does trust play
into that where it's like you don't want
to tell them no don't go and hang out
with your friends because they're going
to a club I mean to me that just seems
like well I was I was I say you you
can't control a girl you obviously can't
do that so you're gonna stay inside the
only thing you could control is what you
do and how you respond you want to go
cool you're single when you come back
but but there's got to be a line here
right but
but no that's not manipulation at all
but but let's have any boundaries and
not acting on that example
hold on let me get my example sure go
ahead uh one year relationship she's
going out with her friends celebrating a
birthday party sure thing 15 girls are
gonna be there she's known forever you
would tell her no you can't go to that
because you're going to a club I would
tell her you can go and do whatever you
do but you will be single when you
return but why why why does that make
sense to throw out a relationship like
that that otherwise is good because if
she respects you she wouldn't have went
in the first place but that seems like
more like an ultimatum that you're
placing on it's not ultimatum she has a
choice to make okay that's an ultimatum
no no it's like no no you can do she's
completely free to do whatever she wants
because the thing is is that she's
putting the she's putting the
relationship in a risky situation why
why would she be don't you would you
trust me because let's be honest here
what are nightclubs for well here's the
thing so I will say in general oh okay
in general yeah nightclubs are for
meeting other people because
Mommy I have boyfriends and we're like
yo boyfriend we didn't even know it's
like legit bro funny bachelorette
parties bro oh my God yeah it's crazy a
bunch of girls oh they're just chilling
by themselves before it's a gang of guys
in there in their roommate I'm just
saying bro things happen so don't be
dumb about it be smart here's the thing
here's the thing I refuse to give a
woman the comfort of security with me as
her boyfriend while she can
simultaneously and behave as though
she's single I have boundaries and
standards and this is what it comes with
it because the thing is is that if a
girl truly respects you she's not going
to want to go to the club she's not
going to want to be around her friends
that want to go ahead and do all this
extra stuff because yeah like like she's
not going to want to behave like she's
single when she's with a man that she
actually admires and respects and my
thing is if she wants to go to Club
that's cool but you no longer are in a
relationship with me because I'm not
going to look stupid sitting at home
while you go out and behave like you're
single that's this is the first point I
actually would say I have a pretty
strong disagreement fair enough look if
you trust your partner and you trust
their friends because also it's you your
due diligence as your you know your
partner's partner to get to know her
friends and to understand who she likes
hanging out with because she probably
wants that too and if you can trust
everybody and they're all going out to
the club and she wants to have a good
time I feel like there's nothing wrong
with that but if you set this now
ultimate him but if you make this
apparent and it's a boundary at this
boundary apparent in the beginning of
the relationship such as hey if we're
dating I don't want you going to the
club it makes me uncomfortable uh would
you do me the respect of not going to
the club I think that's fine because
that's just a preference at that point
right and I think all preferences are
probably never been to a club yeah
website Club yeah
people dance well
drink
what does that lead to dancing and
drinking sex that is one of the
potential outcomes but that that's not a
one-to-one ratio it's not like you just
so here's the thing I did it here's I
think this is where I disconnected you
can dance and do that this is where the
disconnect is disconnect is this I think
you guys grossly underestimate like how
easy it is for women to get sex and
since it's easy for women to get sex a
threshold for them to cheat is also
easier as well it's a slight a skill
that works together like for men it's
very difficult to get sex doesn't mean
they always want sex though because it's
always available it doesn't mean they're
going to take it but here's my thing
yeah I look at it if your girl is out
dressed provocatively and seeking
attention that is cheating and some
people might look at me like whoa what
do you mean it's because men and women
are different a man has to actually go
out there put his nuts on the line talk
to a girl to initiate some type of
interaction women don't do that women
rarely if ever approach men how do they
do it they do it by exposing their
sexuality men show their Charisma women
show their bodies how would that be any
different from a guy driving down with
like you know a Bentley convertible with
a nice watch on because you still got to
put in work you still have to put in
work to get that girl even though the
Bentley and the watch all it does it
gives you another 20 seconds to to that
is to build attraction if anything like
it's still very difficult as a man even
let's say you got a Bentley and a nice
watch and everything else like that a
girl will still curb you like but a girl
on the other hand she could go into a
club going ah and dudes will still smash
her but if you go into the club you're
gonna go to jail you know what I mean
like it's not the same I think if you do
that with confidence you walk it through
me I do they're gonna be like yeah
good waiver
she will be a dragon for that because
that is who you are but the thing is is
that so the people hate this but the
reality is there is a double standard
men and women are not the same there's
behaviors that are completely
unacceptable for women and there's
unacceptable for men and that's okay and
my thing is is that women get mad at
double standards that don't benefit them
that's where they complain about
so I wanted to point out a couple things
do you notice how guys that are more
blue pill always use partner in their
language because again they're in a more
egalitarian model we are equal like that
that is their mindset and I I really
think I was trying to think of a similar
equivalent of a woman going to a club
and I was thinking maybe a man on a
dating app but even that isn't the same
um because again you're putting a girl
in a situation where men like you're
basically saying go to this club where
50 men are gonna try to sleep with you
at the same time why do women feel
entitled to acting the same way in a
relationship as you do single
and it's interesting because we expect
men to change when they're single like I
don't think most women want their guy
going to a strip club they don't want
their guy you know going on boys trips
but we expect to be able to go to a club
like my question is if this is a woman
you want to be a wife and a mother why
does she want to be in the club while
dating you and it's interesting too they
don't really have a firm grasp on female
nature and I used to I used to find this
a little offensive so I kind of
understand like when you first hear it
it sounds trigger triggering but it's
like women we are so easy to to
propagate like they Elites have known
this for over a hundred years women if
you just tell us things like get in our
ear you can literally convince us of
goddamn anything I mean look it we we
could be anything for because of
feminism feminism said women you can do
whatever you want and a lot of us just
decided to go be horse
that that was the best outcome like
think of this this is how easy to
maneuver and manipulate so what
and and it and it shows in the data like
women are much more likely to get
divorced when their friends get divorced
there's a reason that we follow fashion
trends right
women are like packed animals and if you
get the wrong group of women the wrong
chick in her ear women just kind of go
left and the point that Myron is making
is that
why would you put a girl in a situation
that is going to compromise your
relationship like why would you allow a
woman to constantly put herself in
situations that compromise her
relationships there's nothing wrong with
getting to know her friends but if her
friends want to go to the club all of
the time what does that say about her
and I think a wise woman limits
you know the type of friends she brings
around and the friends understand that
you're not going to move the same way in
a relationship that you would single
it's kind of a more like egalitarian
model we are the same where Myron has a
more
um
hierarchy I mean he doesn't flat out say
this but again it's it's that the woman
should follow his lead and a girl that
is going to be in a relationship with
him has to operate under his rules and I
think that relationships would be more
successful if men had this mindset but
the problem is we tell men that they
should just accept anything in a
relationship that a woman can act
exactly the same in a relationship as
she does single and it's like if a girl
goes to a club she's gonna have a bunch
of dudes hitting on her if a guy goes to
a club like
I mean he might get eyes maybe if he's
good looking it's it's just not the same
imagine our mothers I mean some of
y'all's mothers maybe did do this
imagine our grandmothers and her
great-grandmothers arguing for the right
to go to the club
that's what we're arguing for
and that's what we've convinced the men
to defend us for doing
a right to go to the club and the whole
point is a woman may be a good woman but
even a good woman around the wrong
friends can be a bad woman and it's kind
of it's the guy's responsibility
if she's operating under his rules
to really protect us from ourselves to
be honest because we just like get
around a group of people we get the
wrong social media thrown at us and we
just think things and start believing
things now I don't say this to be mean
but guys it's just when you interview
hundreds of women and they all have like
the same conclusion that's like men are
abusers like where did we get this idea
that the men are the abusers propaganda
it's not in real life where did we get
this idea that
women are equal to men where because
it's not in society it's very clear when
we look around in real life and who runs
and operates Society it is the men but
yet still in our head we are equal still
in our head these men are these abusers
these gracists when it's not real but
what they'll do is they'll just get in
our ear and they'll do it in school
they'll get in our ear they'll they'll
take over our institutions with all the
studies and say this is a a study that
says something that's not true they'll
get in our ear they'll get in our ear
for social media get in our ear they'll
brainwash all of our friends get in our
ear and then boom
we're on only fans at 37 years old you
have open relationships like all of this
craziness is following the woman's lead
it's not following the man's lead
because men are a lot more logical women
we operate on emotions first we want to
fit in and I think evolutionarily like
we had to fit in in order to survive but
you know maybe I'm crazy
maybe your girlfriend should just go to
the club send her to the club and have a
happy healthy relationship well guys
um
at to conclude today let your chick go
to the club just let her send her have
fun
um also women have very valid reasons
for divorce and I'm just a big meanie
bad guy Pearl is just a big meanie
who just doesn't know what she's talking
about see there's no trends at all in
society I'm just a big meanie uh but let
me know what you guys think in the
comments like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time